un monde à part maintenant vous ou vos
enfants le connaissaient peut-être celui
des jeux vidéo une console régné presque
sans partage la fameuse game boy et bien
le groupe sony contre attaque
un lancement en grande pompe hier soir à
minuit frédéric mentait alexandra la
livraison d'un stock de surgelés non
l'essai d'une nouvelle blouse
d'infirmière non plus un film
hollywoodien avec des men in white
alors là vous brûlez minuit pile hier
soir à paris la course à la playstation
portable est lancé dans ce magasin mille
exemplaires achetés en deux heures
seulement
que 150 euros la console peu importe le
prix
nous avons l'impression quand même
d'être victime un peu d'un marketing
effrénée dans sony bref une console de
plus sur un marché très lucratif en 2004
les jeux vidéo dépasse le cinéma en
chiffre d'affaires dans la famille
rodriguez le règlement intérieur prévoit
trois heures de jeu par semaine
bah moi je trouve que c'est pas
intéressant du tout j'ai essayé moi même
d'y jouer vraiment je trouve ça d'une
débilité même complètement et parents
mais c'est pas trop de leur génération
c'est plutôt don camillo et compagnie
quant aux psychiatres fan d'échecs en
noir et blanc sur palm moi je suis pas
sûr que ce soit pire de jouer aux jeux
vidéo que de regarder la télévision paul
nom bien vu car en moyenne les français
passent trois heures et 22 minutes par
jour devant leur télé contre une heure
de jeu vidéo quotidienne chez les accros
de la manette